When Kumail Nanjiani was cast in Marvel's
Eternals, he was determined to step up his game
to play the samurai Kingo Sunen and challenged
himself to look the part. Here are the secrets
the star and his personal trainer Grant Roberts
have revealed behind his bulking up journey.
After seeing Kumail Nanjiani's photos of his
physical transformation, plenty of people
wondered how he got those incredible results
— and if they could potentially recreate his
success on their own. However, Nanjiani
has been open about the fact that his
results would not have been possible if he
wasn't in a position of immense privilege.
He worked with personal trainers and
nutritionists throughout the year,
all of whom were focused on creating
a custom program for his body, goals,
and lifestyle. Nanjiani wrote
in his Instagram caption,
"I would not have been able to do this if I
didn't have a full year with the best trainers and
nutritionists paid for by the biggest studio in
the world. I'm glad I look like this, but I also
understand why I never did before. It would have
been impossible without these resources and time."
Over the course of his fitness journey,
Kumail Nanjiani worked with many top
personal trainers and nutritionists, all
of whom played an important role in helping
him achieve his goals. But he spent most
of his time training with Grant Roberts,
who has also worked as an actor — you might
have spotted him in Sully, or in films like
Million Dollar Baby. Being in front of the
camera himself meant that he understood
exactly what Nanjiani needed to do in order to
prepare for Eternals. Roberts told Page Six,
"My process is completely individualized and
starts with the gathering of information.
Current lifestyle, body composition tests, etc. I
also have a 3D scanner that's particularly useful
for goal setting [...] and strategizing
the nutrition and training program."
The 3D body scanner that Roberts uses probably
doesn't come cheap, but these machines
create accurate pictures of his client's body
composition, posture, and how their measurements
change as they work out. It was an invaluable
tool for creating Nanjiani's training program.
"He scares me. Me too. But
he's an excellent motivator."
So, if you want to get muscles like Nanjiani,
how often do you have to hit the gym? Nanjiani
generally worked out for a little over an hour,
four to five days a week. However,
recovery time was an important component
of his fitness program. He consistently
took two or three days off each week.
Many people think that they need to push
themselves to work out without taking a day off
if they want to bulk up or lose weight,
but having scheduled rest days so that
your muscles can heal is actually
crucial. Roberts definitely wanted
Nanjiani to commit to a rigorous workout
schedule, but as a professional trainer,
he also understood that regular rest days
would be the key to long-term success.
Spending time relaxing outside of the gym is
just as important as spending time in the gym!
They say that abs are made in the kitchen, and
this was definitely true for Nanjiani. Getting fit
wasn't just about burning calories in the
gym — he also had to ensure that he was
fueling his body with healthy foods.
Sure, you can technically lose weight
while eating sugary desserts or savory comfort
foods, but when it comes to building muscle,
you need to start with the right building
blocks and put nutritious foods on your plate.
What was included in Nanjiani's food pyramid? He
went with the low-carb approach to dieting. He
also made sure to eat plenty of protein, which
is essential for building muscle and having a
sustained source of energy for workouts. Nanjiani
also focused on adding healthy fats to his diet,
particularly sources of omega-3 fatty
acids. In addition, he made sure to
drink plenty of water and stay hydrated.
If you're exercising as often as he was,
you don't want to forget your water
bottle when you go to the gym.
Many people find that sticking to a consistent,
healthy diet is even more difficult than finding
a form of exercise they enjoy. But for Kumail
Nanjiani, this wasn't the case. He was so
dedicated to his fitness program that he
didn't want to take cheat days. In fact,
one of the nutritionists he worked with
basically had to force him to take a day
off from his diet and indulge every once in
a while. Nanjiani credits David Higgins for
giving him permission to enjoy his favorite
foods and stop being so hard on himself.
What did Nanjiani reach for on
cheat days? He grew up in Pakistan,
and he loves Pakistani food — but he admits
that this cuisine is very carb-heavy,
which meant that it wasn't appropriate for
his usual meal planning. But he says that
traditional Pakistani food, like biryani, naan
bread, and rice, was his, quote, "go-to cheat
meal" — and he would often feel so full after
eating it that he had to take a nap afterward.
When Roberts designed Nanjiani's workout
program, he had a philosophy in mind:
"No weak spots."
Yes, they would target certain muscles, but
overall, he wanted to create full-body workouts.
His goal? Help Nanjiani look like a real
bodybuilder. He encouraged Nanjiani to
concentrate on "the symmetry of the musculature"
so that he would see improvements all over.
Roberts admits that he pushed Nanjiani
in a way that he had never been pushed
before — but Nanjiani was always
up for the challenge. Roberts says
that Nanjiani was genuinely enthusiastic
about getting fit, telling Men's Journal,
"I was excited to work with Kumail because I
could tell he was ready to dedicate himself to
the process. I have literally thousands
of text messages to prove that point.
Getting these kinds of results [doesn't]
happen without maximum effort."
When it comes to helping his clients, Roberts
clearly likes to stay on the cutting edge and
utilize new technology in the world of fitness.
While working with Nanjiani, Roberts regularly
used electric stimulation, or e-stim, to
target certain muscles. Your average gym-goer
may not have used this tool, but apparently
celebrity trainers like Roberts are big fans.
So, how does electric stimulation
work? Basically, Roberts would place
pads hooked up to electric wires on Nanjiani's
back over specific muscle groups. Sometimes,
he would deliver a zap, which helped quote
"fire up" the muscles. It may sound strange,
but Roberts is a fan of using this method with
clients. He used electric stimulation with
Nanjiani about twice per week.
When you start working out and eating healthy, you
don't see results overnight. The waiting game is
frustrating, but it takes a while to notice the
results you really want. However, according to
Roberts, Nanjiani really didn't have to wait long
to see results. This is because Roberts went right
in with workouts that were focused on intensity
— packing lots of action into a short timeframe.
This leads to fast muscle
building and weight loss,
which was probably quite motivating
for Nanjiani. Roberts told Page Six,
"Kumail responded very quickly — as most
people do — when introduced to training
that shocks the system, whether it be for fat loss
or muscle gain or — as in Kumail's case — both."
When Nanjiani started working out to get ready
for Eternals, he felt like he had spent years
holding himself back from his full potential.
He had generally worked in comedy — he was best
known for Silicon Valley and The Big Sick — but
he knew if he wanted to try something different,
he would need to transform his physique.
He had no idea just how strong he could get
because he had never tried to figure
out what his physical limits were.
At one point he was getting so muscular that
Marvel told Roberts and Nanjiani to scale back
and slow down a bit — apparently, he looked,
quote, "too big and too cut" for the role.
Therefore, Roberts lightened up on Nanjiani's
workouts. This probably wasn't the kind
of feedback that Nanjiani expected from
the studio, but it had to be flattering.
"How do you feel?”
“Taller."
The key to seeing amazing results in the gym
isn't just physical exercise — it's also about
your mindset. Kumail Nanjiani said that his
perspective and sheer level of concentration
on his goals were necessary to achieve
the look he wanted. He told Men's Health,
"When I'm exercising, I'm not thinking
about anything else. It's like meditation."
Nanjiani even admitted that some of his
friends were dismayed by his new attitude
towards working out. He says that at one point,
they essentially, quote, "staged an intervention"
to get him out of the gym for a few days.
They were worried that his intense focus on
working out would detract from his skills
as a comedian. Nanjiani knew that outlook
might affect his work on funnier projects,
but he said that in the end, he didn't care.
"I'm kind of obsessed with it."
Being funny wasn't his only priority
anymore — he was ready for a major change,
and he was willing to accept the
sacrifices that would come along with it.
In order to achieve the results he really
wanted, Nanjiani's nutritionists basically
had to micromanage his diet. He had to be
exceptionally careful about eating sugar,
and whenever he ate something
sweet, he had to give them a
heads up so they could plan his meals
accordingly. Nanjiani told Men's Health,
"They were like, 'If you're going
to have a can of Coke today,
let us know in the morning so we
can adjust and account for it.'"
Although he was allowed to enjoy cheat days,
he soon found that after eating such a clean
diet all week long, going on a sugar binge during
the weekends would hold him back when he returned
to the gym. Nanjiani admitted that on one
particular occasion, he decided to indulge
in sticky toffee pudding, but came to regret
it the next day, saying that he felt so, quote,
"off" that he had to endure "twelve hours of
physical pain." He eventually got so strict
with his sugar intake that he ended up going an
entire year without eating even a single brownie.
There's a common mistake that people make when
they begin working out: they try to go all out and
adopt some extreme habits, which inevitably don't
stick. As a personal trainer, Roberts is well
aware of these pitfalls, and he was determined
to help Nanjiani avoid them. Instead, Roberts
made sure that Nanjiani was developing habits that
would be sustainable in the long-term, even after
he dialed back on his original, intense training
schedule. Roberts told The Hollywood Reporter,
"We sent him away in peak physical
condition, but he's had to maintain
that. I give him kudos for being able to
do that, especially when he was working."
It looks like the new Nanjiani is here to stay
— he's come a long way throughout this journey,
and there's no doubt that his skills will
impress audiences when Eternals premieres.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.